before we start with this video which is
part of the greater project pannonia i
want to stop anyone angrily typing in
the comments about me not using the word
majar and the video
this is because even though yes when
they came into central europe they
called themselves the majjar tribes
all their written sources about the
hungarians called them ongrei or unhari
and it is this latin name that today's
english name of hungary comes from and
since i'm going to be dealing with only
early hungarian history
it made sense to call the people the
name they use in the sources
it also makes it more simple to
understand as i won't be switching
between two different names so i hope
you understand
as i mentioned many times in my other
videos on the early slavic history the
9th to 10th century hungarian arrival
into central europe shifted many power
dynamics around the panonian plane and
pretty much paved the way for the
creation of the medieval european
borders we are familiar with today
however at the time the arrival of
nomadic conquering people into the
pannonian plane was just as newsworthy
as the franks fighting another civil war
it was nothing new and nothing
unexpected many conquering tribes have
come to the pannonian plane before the
hungarians and many will most likely
come after them
but to the surprise of many this did not
happen
hungarians were the last nomadic tribe
to come and settle
into the panonian basin but how exactly
did the hungarians come into the
pannonian plane
and what exactly did they do before then
isn't fully known
we have some contemporary writings about
them but these only present a very
fragmented timeline that doesn't even
mention any events before their arrival
into
central europe we also have some
writings by the hungarians themselves
but these were mostly written two to
three hundred years later well
after they were settled and
christianized nonetheless combining all
these sources together along with
archaeology and linguistics can give us
a still fragmented but
more detailed picture of the early
history of the hungarians
today it is mostly agreed although not
without its opponents that the hungarian
language and people came from the larger
ugrafinic group but by this point far
removed
far removed because it is believed that
the hungarians were one of the earliest
ergophonic tribes to venture out of the
euro mountains into the eastern european
plane around 800 bce
making them isolated for much of their
history and significantly influence in
language and culture by various other
people groups they came into contact
with
where exactly the hungarians wear and
wins during this time starting
in around 800 bce to 800 ce
is highly debated but just to give you
an idea
one of the theories is as follows the
hungarians established themselves in the
vicinity of the occu dawn and volga
rivers in around 800 bce
it was here they came into contact with
iranian groups like scythians and
cermentians and
also adopted the nomadic stepper
lifestyle this would also explain the
iranian loanwords in the hungarian
language and maybe even some borrowed
iranian folk tales
then after the hunting migration through
the area around the third and fourth
centuries we know that the iranian
groups got mostly replaced by turkic
groups in the european steps
such as the avars sabirs khazars bolgars
etc
it was here that the hungarians may have
gained some of their turkey cultural
influences and borrowed some of the
turkic words that are in their language
then after the fall of the huns followed
by the subsequent migration of the abvar
slavs and bulgars in the 7th century the
hungarians were forced south into the
now
can aid here they had a complicated
relationship with the kazaars probably
switching between being independent
allies vassals and so on however while
in contact with the kazaars the
hungarians borrowed even more turkic
words and assimilated various new people
groups into their tribe
then due to the push by the varangians
and slavs from the north and their
khazars and pagenets from the east and
south the hungarians slowly moved to the
area known as
ethelcots by the 8th to 9th century now
this is only one of many theories to
explain what happened to the hungarian
people during 800 bce to around
800 ce there's other theories claiming
that the hungarians migrated from the
east of the euro mountains not west
there's some claiming that hungarians
first came out of the euro mountains
south settling near the ural river and
slowly being pushed west and even
some saying they settled all the way
south near the caucasus
etc we may probably never know for sure
what happened to the hungarians during
this time but the facts we know for sure
are as follows hungarians early on
diverged from the larger phenomena group
around the euro mountains they adopted
the nomadic or semi-nomadic stepper
lifestyle and had at some point
iranian slavic but mostly turkic
influences in their language and culture
they were also somehow intertwined at
some point with the politics of the
kazar candidate
lastly we know that when they show up in
the european written records in 9th
century coming from the area known as
etokos today south ukraine they were
very much a polyethnic group that wasn't
a rigidly defined close-knit ethnic
society but a
group of tribes of varying degrees of
ethnic similarity joined together by
common goal
and or alliance and or leader this
doesn't mean they were all completely
different tribes that didn't even speak
the same language
it just means that the hungarians that
came into central europe weren't a
completely homogeneous group of people
as used to be believed before
anything else about the hungarians
outside of what i just listed
is very much guesswork at this point
[Music]
the first certain written record about
the hungarians is from 836 or
37 in the chronicle by george the monk
it states that the hungarian warriors
from ethel cause fought alongside the
bulgarian forces against the byzantines
most likely being paid by the bulgarians
to do so this plausibly wasn't the first
hungarian involvement in europe but it
was the first non-disputed recorded one
and it also perfectly sets presidents
for the hungarians as mercenaries and
raiders since
that's what they mostly did for the next
hundred plus years
the first mention of the hungarians and
western european records comes from
frankish ammos which reported
devastating hungarian raid in
east franchia during the winter of 862
63.
this raid occurred during the rebellion
of karl mann who if you remember from my
western slavic video was supported by
the moravian king rastislav it is
believed that the hungarians came due to
caramels but
mainly rastyslav's request to help aid
in the rebellion
this is further supported by the fact
that in a 9th century letter from
salzburg bishopric
we learned that the hungarians were
often times fighting on the side of the
moravians so rastus loves enticement of
the hungarians to come help him and
kawaman during this time wouldn't be
that far-fetched
huh hungarians and moravians fighting
together
who would have thought anyways the
hungarians came back in 881
again on the side of the moravians
fighting against the franks
after this event we don't have any
accounts mentioning the hungarians up
until 892. however it is almost certain
that during this time they orchestrated
numerous frequent raids into their
neighboring realms and
ended their long-standing alliance with
the moravians for reasons we don't know
then in 892-894 hungarians
allied themselves with the franks and
helped the frankish king arnold
to basically [ __ ] moravia at the
height of its power
this two-sided attack along with the
death of sweater poke destroyed any
moravian control in the panonian basin
and threw the entire kingdom into
disarray with sweat uploads sons
fighting amongst each other over control
this meant that even though western
pannonia was taken by the franks
eastern pannonia had a power vacuum it
is plausible that during this time the
hungarians established frontier military
outposts in eastern panonia to cement
their control on the newly conquered
territory but this is unclear
nonetheless in 895 the hungarians turned
their attention to the bulgars who
arrived at the very gates of
constantinople the byzantine emperor leo
vi
asked the hungarians for help who took
this opportunity and started raiding the
bulgarian kingdom
due to this they managed to destroy any
kind of remaining bulgarian control in
transylvania
finally opening up the entire area for a
plausible settlement the bulgarians had
no choice but to retreat from
constantinople and
face the hungarian army head on the
hungarians saved constantinople
and to thank them leo vi made a quick
peace treaty with the bulgars and left
the hungarians out to dry
the hungarians were now stuck in an
unfavorable war and to add to all this
the bulgars sent envoys to the pechenex
asking them to destroy the hungarian
homeland while they deal with the main
army
it was during this time that some of the
hungarians being attacked by the
pechenik started to migrate across the
carpathians the following year in 896
the hungarians were defeated by the
bulgaris and retreated back home where
they found that
all their women and children were either
killed or taken away by the pechenegs
the author of the analyst fodences
continues to say that after this
they decided to seek greener pastures as
well as
women to bear their children west of the
carpathians
more specifically the lands they have
just helped release from the moravian
and bulgarian control
whether the hungarians already
controlled the area through
aforementioned military outposts
since around 892 or just returned to the
area with the intention of reconquering
it in 895
96 is unknown nonetheless even if that
were true the main hungarian settlement
in eastern panonia and transylvania
still started in around 895 and
continued pretty much until 900.
in 898 arnold still having his alliance
with the hungarians used them to raid
into the northern italian lands as he
had lots of trouble subduing that area
under his control
however as the hungarians returned to
pannonia in 900 they found out that
arnold died
meaning their alliance with the franks
ended with this news when they resumed
their frequent raids on the neighboring
realms they also ventured into the
frankish kingdom
due to this in 1901 franks and moravians
bitter rivals for almost 100 years
signed a peace treaty and started a
defensive cooperation against the
hungarian incursions the events of the
next five years are uncertain
we can gather from short mentions in
some annals that the moravian frankish
alliance managed to defend itself until
about 903 but then it seemed like the
hungarians started to gain an upper hand
in the following year the hungarians
raided again into italy this time
helping the italian principalities
against the frankish king
and they also managed to annex at some
point the frankish controlled western
pannonia then in 906 they took control
of the remaining moravian lands defeated
the bohemians and raided
all the way north into saxony they also
created many new settlements in these
newly conquered territories moving the
center of the hungarian population more
westward
by 907 the hungarian control stretched
from the rivers
of morava and latha all the way down to
sava and the danube
they basically controlled the entire
panonian plane but this control was
fragile at best
they needed a clear and decisive victory
against the franks to solidify these
newly conquered holdings and
so the stage was set for the battle of
presburg however before continuing i
want to address the fact why i haven't
talked much about
internal hungarian affairs during this
video this is because all the
contemporary sources that exist from
that time don't talk about this
the only two sources that do talk about
this are the gesta hungarorum
and chronic on pictum written in the
13th and 14th century respectively
way after the 9th and 10th centuries
conquest of the hungarians
plus a lot of their accounts of early
hungarian history is purely fictional
like almost the father of arpad being
related to
attila the han or the whole story of the
blood oath
to add to all this these two sources
often times contradict each other so at
best
one of them has to be made up due to all
this historians reluctantly use these
sources alone when dealing with the
early hungarian history and
try to combine them wherever possible
with outside writings
hence the historical view is mostly
lacking in hungarian internal affairs
with that said there are things we can
tell with pretty good certainty thanks
to this approach
for example we know that the hungarians
had a dual monarchy system with one
ruler being a religious figure and the
other a military one
we also know that these rulers during
the hungarian panonian conquest were
arpat
and kurzan however in 904 when the
hungarians started to gain the upper
hand and the panonian conquest the
frankish king louis iii
asked kurzan to come to the frankish
banquet for peace negotiations
corzano obliged but when he showed up
the franks quickly killed him
along with his entourage the frankish
nobles were hoping this would cause
chaos within the hungarian tribes as
their
ruler was now dead but since there was
still arpat
he just assumed both of the king's roles
ending the hungarian system of dual
monarchs and since arpad was technically
the first king of the hungarians
he's the one celebrated as the leader
who brought his people to pannonia
the date of arpat's death along with who
was his successor
is uncertain but we do know for sure he
didn't live past 907
which brings us back to the battle of
pressburg today's bratislava
even though this battle is one of the
most important battles in hungarian
history
it is surrounded with lots of
uncertainty for example the only
complete source we have on the battle
comes from a 16th century writer
johannes turmeyer he claims to be
working from primary frankish sources
that have been since lost to time but
that hasn't stopped some historians
doubting his writings
with that said i'm going to be
presenting his version of the battle in
this video but before then here's the
list of all the things we know for sure
that happened after meyer's entire
writings are disregarded
yeah that's it historians can't even
agree on the exact location of the
battle if turmeric is disregarded
with that said the reason for the
frankish army entering hungarian lands
in 907 was
threefold a defeat the hungarian army so
they will stop their raiding expeditions
into francia
b reconquer the lost frankish lands of
pannonia
c free moravia and incorporate it into
the frankish kingdom
basically the franks looked at this
expedition as a big hail mary to destroy
the hungarians just as trial maine did
with the avars in the 8th and 9th
century
at the head of the frankish army was the
barbarian duke leutepold who continued
this idea of walking in the footsteps of
chalamet by entering the hungarian
territory the same way charlemagne did
he divided his army into three smaller
armies one marching on the north side of
the danube of which he took command
the order on the south side of the
danube and the last one sailing on the
danube
acting as a communication and supply
bridge between the two
however problems started right away as
the hungarians employed a nomadic hit
and run method
constantly harassing both sides of the
frankish army this resulted in a large
confusion among the divided armies and
due to this confusion the army on the
south bank managed
to march way ahead of the two other
armies they decided to stop so the rest
of the army could catch up but that's
when the hungarians attacked in full
force destroying the entire unprepared
south bank army without the rest of the
army and even knowing about it
when night fell luthepol decided to make
camp somewhere near pressburg
or pratislava or pojon thinking he will
catch up to the south bank army tomorrow
however the hungarians under the cover
of knight crossed the danube and
attacked the unsuspecting frankish camp
killing most of the soldiers along with
leutbold himself
the next day the hungarians destroyed
the danubian fleet by setting it on fire
with fire arrows
and so the battle of presburg was over
hungarians had their decisive victory
and solidified their control over the
entire pannonian plane along with all
the people living in it
this battle made it clear to everyone
that the hungarians were here to stay
and so the next chapter of the hungarian
history began
the central european chapter
thank you for watching my video i hope
you're enjoying project pannonia the
video before mine in the collaboration
is by quillin inc history talking about
the avars and the video after mine and
the collaboration is by history time
talking about the christianization of
the now settled hungarians
if you enjoyed my video please consider
subscribing and stick around
for history
you